what would you tell someone who says
it's impossible to shoot a feature film
in five days
i would say that's not entirely accurate
a feature film runs 90 minutes so you
could put a camera on your cat on the
table for 90 minutes boom you got
yourself feature film that's all that's
all it took 90 minutes so technically
that is true that you can make a feature
film under five days
now with your film your documentary
how many days of shooting the total
shooting days of hours
was
seven days
we shot a four day event so we had
camera teams running around for four
days and then we did three days of
interviews
about 16 hours of interviews
and were these spontaneous interviews or
did you let the people know ahead of
time that you would be meeting with them
no they were not spontaneous they were
set up interviews we actually did for
our documentary we did everyone's
interviews before the convention
happened except for the one main owner
so then we shot the four days the
convention and then we did his interview
after to help recap
some of the crazy events that had
happened
and was any of this scripted did you
have a three-act structure for your
documentary not at all it was definitely
trial by fire i think but
i got called in by the owners of the
convention we were old friends and they
called me down to help you know try to
do this documentary on what they thought
would be their last
major super con event
and so
i knew kind of how i wanted to do it i
wanted to play off them showing a
behind-the-scenes only focus on the
documentary because it already had a
couple comic-con documentaries that
showed it from the fans perspective or
from a different angle but no one's ever
really shown it just from
behind the scenes
and so
we knew we only had to shoot for four
days because it's only a four-day event
but we ran around for 18 to 20 hours a
day
with a different camera team attached to
each person that was running the show
and so
yeah i mean that was seven days which we
could have done it unless but we
did a second round of interviews that we
added another day for
um
for some extraneous interviews
and how did you deal with crowd control
and their reaction to the camera
well luckily conventions when you enter
the premises there's giant signs saying
that we have the ability to videotape
and photograph you here for purposes for
multiple purposes so
they don't really have any say in that
and the building that we were doing a
documentary the police department knew
we were doing a documentary some of the
celebrities i think knew
and so it wasn't um a secret to anyone
and so we didn't really have any issues
with that and then everything we covered
was truth i mean the entire movie is a
fly on the wall experience we didn't set
up anything we didn't organize any
scenes we literally just ran around and
followed the action
and then cut out all the boring parts
because there's a lot of action that
happens so it was pretty easy to build
build a story off of how did you know
there was going to be enough story
to make a film
i guess starting out you never really
know
how big your story is going to be or
what's going to be more of the focus i
had a general idea that
whatever we
didn't need of show footage we have
interviews to help out so i had a good
idea that we would have 90 minutes worth
of content
i didn't know exactly how exciting it
would be or what would happen until the
actual show started happening and then
each day when we would find a new
storyline we would jot down notes uh my
main camera operator chris mcdaniel had
dp'd a bunch of reality shows so he had
some good notes for us on okay you know
if you catch something but you don't
catch it verbally just ask them to
repeat what just happened you know grab
a shot of this grab a shot of that and
so between the four teams we covered
almost everything pretty well
including some things with four angles
which was really neat to see all
different sides of some of the stories
but yeah i never really worried about
having enough content
and i knew i wanted to focus on building
the story lines of these three main
people
because we were telling their story on
on how they built the show we start from
them being born all the way through what
they built up after 12 years of this
this convention which was this major 60
000 person event
and so you knew these characters before
the show even started so when you see
them go through all of these hip hoops
and hurdles you're you're feeling a lot
more for them hopefully because you know
them now a lot better as opposed to just
that guy's doing this so you get to see
their whole upbringing and kind of grow
to like them a little bit more i think
who are the three people in the film so
the documentary follows the two owners
husband and wife team of michael broder
and sandy martin and then josh patron as
their head of operations and so these
are the three main people we follow
throughout the documentary the husband
and wife team that started the show and
then josh is running around all three of
them run around constantly putting out
different fires all over the massive
convention center
was there footage that you felt
you shouldn't include
that you don't have to tell me what it
was but for whatever reason it was cut
because
you didn't have someone's approval or
no there was only there was one
storyline that we didn't have enough
footage for that we probably could have
used but we made a con
we made a deal with the police
department pretty quickly of what we
were allowed to shoot and we were not
allowed to shoot such as if someone gets
arrested and we videotape the arrest
that turns into evidence they have to
confiscate our footage and cameras which
we didn't want to have happen
so
things like that but we didn't need it
we built up the story lines up into the
arresting point and you just didn't see
the person going to the police car it's
pretty simple
um
all of the story lines that we cut were
just not as exciting i had probably over
an hour footage of parking problems
easily could have done a whole movie on
parking problems but it's not nearly as
exciting as
a fire alarm going off or someone
getting arrested or an ambulance taking
somebody away
so
so yeah we definitely
i'm not a big documentarian and i'm not
a big documentary fan really so for me i
kind of put it together as entertaining
as possible and as fast paced as
possible because that's the kind of
movie i would want to watch
and a lot of people have told us that
like this is a lot of fun like it's so
funny and it's really cool so that was
kind of the ultimate goal too so you
wanted to make a light documentary not
not a heavy
sort of message driven there's
definitely heavy parts in it because
there was a lot going on in the country
over that weekend it's a very
it's a very specific weekend 2018
of july and so
you had
the interim camps
nearby in south florida for all of the
immigrant children you had the parkland
massacre happen nearby the convention as
well that impacted the convention
there's a hurricane about to hit the
state at the time there are other things
happening outside that was important to
touch on that that had direct effect
with the convention as well and the
parkland was definitely the biggest
factor that we touch on in the movie
uh and i had a lot of people that you
know every time we show it in theaters
that start bawling during that part
because it's such a
such a difficult
thing to watch and you know to to talk
about again
why didn't you say no to this project
since you said you're not really a huge
documentary fan they offered me money
that's a good reason
um
the broder's called me up and said look
we want to do this project you're the
filmmaker we we like and we know
and you know we'll hire your crew we'll
put you guys up we'll pay for the whole
thing and you can come down and kind of
build this movie for us and i was like
sure of course you know i would love to
do you know i like to do any kind of
movie really so it was an opportunity
and
it was already financed and so i was
like yeah sounds great and i'd been to
the convention multiple times and they
were good friends of mine and it was
only a four-day shoot so i was like oh
we're gonna shoot this entire movie in a
week that's great that's perfect that's
really short and so we ended up having
about three months of post editing
and then sound mix and score
so maybe about
about five or six months of post but
yeah i mean shooting it was really easy
it was well at least it was fast
shooting in only a few days so i thought
overall it sounded good and i wasn't
doing anything that week so
we made it happen what was the biggest
challenge you faced while filming it the
biggest challenge i think we faced
filming it was just trying to be
everywhere at once you know it's a
massive building and there's 60 000
people and you're pushing and shoving
and trying to follow different things
and and you would want to break you know
you're carrying a camera rig around for
hours and hours and hours and there was
a couple times where like okay i got to
grab some food and i would step out grab
some food and like oh you missed this
thing it's like well of course i missed
it because i need to eat a piece of
pizza for
you know for 10 hours of running around
but i think that was the physical
challenges were the most challenging i
think for us just running around
and just worrying that you were we were
going to miss something because it's a
it's an in the moment or a deal
and sometimes we break away to go shoot
an interview or something and then
something might happen
but overall i i was never
not confident about the movie being
there i thought we had plenty of pieces
and plenty of story lines that that'll
all be fine i think it's more so just
about staying awake and not passing out
while holding the camera and
catching everything that you possibly
could
and so when you brought the footage back
to start piecing it together did you
have an editor or you did it yourself i
did all the editing myself
and luckily i i knew everything because
i was there for every single shoot i was
there for every interview and i had lots
of notes that i'd written down like i
think we should touch on this thing we
should focus on this
so i had kind of a good timeline when we
got back of how i was gonna cut the
movie
um we had about eight terabytes of
footage and 16 hours of interviews
to go through everything was 4k
we shot with four different cameras
and um then time lapses and stuff so
it just took time you know going through
everything and i made individual
timelines for each storyline so you'd be
like all right here's oh they touch on
this drop it in that folder touch on
this drop it in that folder so i went
through all the footage that we had and
organized everything and then just
broken little scenes little chunks and
started cutting it together like that
and at what point do you show the rough
cut to the the is it the three people
involved or there are more people i did
uh i did a pretty good rough cut i
showed it to a couple friends here to
get some notes before i show it to them
some of their filmmaking friends just
because i was like does this make sense
i've been watching this for 10 000 hours
i don't even know what it is anymore and
got some notes based on that made some
tweaks
and then showed them a somewhat
like a decent rough cut
and
they uh i had nightmares that
mike was gonna show up and like choke me
in my sleep like after watching the
movie because it's definitely a warts
and all documentary like it shows
the best and the worst i think of of
them too
and so
they both were like wow this is a real
movie and i was like yeah that was the
plan
was to make a real movie
and i think both of them i mean it was
very difficult for them to watch just to
kind of see this is their entire life
story sure and we're showcasing their
life story and we're showing them in
in great moments and compromising
moments essentially so
but overall they were really really
happy with it and we just you know
locked it locked picture and did the
rest of post and
knocked it out and then did a few
festivals
and um and then yeah and now it's it's
out streaming everywhere and blu-ray dvd
and it's good to go
do you have that talk with people
beforehand
that i'm going to shoot things that
you know
you're going to see all
sides of you and and you may not like it
you know i
didn't have that conversation with them
because he can be really scary sometimes
and
but i did tell them was look
we're shooting this documentary but
you're still going to get to watch it
and have finals say if we do something
that's slanderous like i don't want to
slander anybody across the board we only
slam to the building because the
building caused the huge
legal nightmare
which is explained in the documentary
we do slender them but you know we don't
sign to the police we don't slander the
fans or the celebrities or anything like
that because we don't need to it's not
it's not that kind of a movie
um
and i was like if you watch something
where it's and you're like we can't have
this i mean let me know and we'll
discuss it but we didn't have anything
like that we didn't run any problems
and and even though some people were
like oh well this is a little too
one-sided on their behalf and i'm like
well i guess it's only one-sided because
i didn't interview all the people that
caused problems
i didn't interview the kid that got
arrested for stealing thousands of
dollars with the badges
i didn't interview the policemen that
arrested some like there's things like
that because it's not their story
it's this story
um
but i think it works out really well and
it balances i mean you see them in crazy
situations and then you see them having
a good time and so it's like every movie
it's a roller coaster it should be sure
but i think it's so much different when
it's a narrative when people they don't
want to see themselves even if they're
having let's say a bad hair day or they
have bags under their eyes can you take
that out
and you're like well no i mean that
shows that's you right there i want to
show you right you know i just just a
full human being not only perfect you
know and they were totally fine with
that and i think they
they understood the importance
of it all
and it showcases what they go through i
mean this is they're killing themselves
trying to make this thing happen and it
really showcases that and i think
they're appreciative of that and people
that have watched it have told them like
wow like you guys are crazy and this is
amazing that you do all this stuff to
make this show happen to make all of
these people
happy and and it really opened my eyes
to conventions on why conventions are so
important
and so inclusive and it's really
incredible what they have become and i
really appreciate that now a lot more